los llaman chantaje del gas el gigante
energético ruso gazprom informó que
interrumpió el suministro de gas a
bulgaria y polonia a través de su
gasoducto yamal-europa y se produce
después de que los dos países se negaron
a pagar en rublos por el gas natural
nuestros miembros de la otan y de la
unión europea reciben una parte
importante de su suministro de moscú
después de que occidente buscará
alejarse de la dependencia rusa para
debilitar el arma energética de putin la
ministra polaca del clima restó
importancia al impacto de una
interrupción repentina
desde el primer día hemos transmitido el
mensaje de que estamos dispuestos a
independizarnos totalmente de los
combustibles fósiles de rusia desde la
guerra de rusia contra ucrania el país
tiene previsto dejar de importar gas
ruso a finales de año tras la expiración
de su contrato con el gigante energético
ruso gazprom y ya están en marcha los
preparativos para diversificar sus
suministros de gas natural polonia
recibe gas natural licuado en su
terminal del vinobús y espinoza a partir
del primero de mayo del gasoducto gpl a
la red polaca con lituania y un
gasoducto la tubería del báltico
suministrar gas desde noruega este
gasoducto que estará listo a finales de
octubre podría sustituir todas las
entregas rusas de gas natural alemán ya
que ya ha reducido su dependencia del
gas ruso en el 55 el 40 por ciento dice
que apoyará a polonia
podemos abastecer a estas refinerías con
la reserva nacional para garantizar la
solidaridad por nuestra parte es decir
podemos utilizar las reservas nacionales
de petróleo para garantizar las
transacciones de las refinerías y apoyar
a polonia en
polonia y bulgaria son sólo dos de los
muchos países europeos que se negaron a
pagar el gas ruso en rublos rusia
advirtió que cortaría el suministro a
todos los países que no cumplieran